[Musique]
c'est une société qui est spécialisée
dans la connectique électronique qui a
été créée en 1957 par Monsieur takarachi
et aujourd'hui c'est madame nishimoto
qui gère la société avec son fils de
docteur nishimoto on est présent sur
tous les marchés
électroniques vous prenez n'importe quel
appareil chez vous que ce soit
électroménager appareil mobile un
véhicule partout vous avez électronique
vous avez des connecteurs JST c'est une
société qui a été créée en 1957 qui a
une part de marché importante sur le
monde de l'automobile où vous retrouvez
les connecteurs JST dans tout ce qui est
éclairage dans le tableau de bord dans
le système de sécurité avec les airbags
partout vous avez électronique au sein
du véhicule vous avez des connecteurs JT
[Musique]
il est proche de nos clients savoir
c'était lentilles Renault Valeo qui sont
des clients à fort potentiel pour projet
St et on développe un partenariat depuis
plus de 20 ans être proche du client
c'est vraiment dans l'axe de la manière
d'agir de la culture japonaise au moins
de l'entreprise c'est customer need
c'est le besoin du client et client a
besoin d'avoir ses fournisseurs à lui
[Musique]
un certain rayonnement du fait que on
est à 30 km de Paris que on peut arriver
à Saint-Quentin sans feu rouge par
l'autoroute fait des éléments quand même
de compétitivité très content d'avoir un
acteur aussi puissant plus ça me sur des
secteurs extrêmement stratégiques
d'ailleurs leur premier client sont des
clients qui sont à 50 ans en Yvelines
notamment sur l'automobile ou que ce
soit Validéo que ce soit tous le secteur
automobile
[Musique]
qui en suit le planning on rentrera dans
les locaux au même moment que les Jeux
Olympiques R&D principalement centre
commercial européen voilà développé être
proche de du client aller voir les
clients pour pouvoir développer pour eux
des nouvelles connectiques électroniques
à l'intérieur de l'entreprise il faut
qu'on soit comme comme à la maison pour
être bien donc si on est bien au travail
on va fournir un travail de qualité
[Musique]